hey everyone i'm abby from abby's
kitchen welcome back to our series
enlightened by intuitive eating in our
last video we discussed principle number
eight of intuitive eating
respect your body so if you haven't
watched that video yet
definitely go check it out right here
and then come back to watch this one
now before we get started i want to flag
that this content may not be for all of
my viewers
so feel free to take and leave what you
find valuable
i also want to remind you to check out
evelyn tripoli and elise rush's book
which i've linked below and a big thank
you to intuitive eating
dietitian alyssa rumsey for reviewing
this content
i will leave her contact in the
description below so that you can reach
out
for any one-on-one consults now let's
get to our reader question
and baby is kicking dear abby
if my set point has gone up from dieting
is it possible for it to come back down
from intuitive eating
that is a really good question for those
of you who don't know
setpoint theory suggests that the body
works to maintain a predetermined weight
range
through regulation of metabolism
essentially the body will slow the
metabolism down when underfed
and increase the metabolism when overfed
to minimize
large changes in one's weight your body
is really trying to keep you alive so
it will put in various mechanisms to try
to prevent a person from
losing weight well below their set point
weight range
this is exactly why most people who lose
weight will end up
regaining that weight over time your
body will fight
really freaking hard to get back to
where it's most comfortable
for a lot of people this setpoint weight
range is not
in the normal bmi range diversity
in body sizes is normal just like there
are diversity in heights
or shoe size so not everyone's set point
is going to be in that
normal bmi range and that's okay
over time it is possible that dieting
may cause your setpoint weight range to
increase
when people start working on intuitive
eating and reconnecting with their
body's
internal cue system over time your body
does
tend to naturally settle into a weight
range that is right
for you but it's impossible to know what
that weight range
is i mean you don't know that and i
don't know that
some people lose weight during this
process of intuitive eating while others
stay the same
and others gain also our weight is not
static over time
it it really does ebb and flow depending
on our situation
our life stage and our environment
this is why i encourage you to try to
put your weight
and your set point range on the back
burner as you go through these exercises
we don't know what your body is going to
do all we can do is work towards
reconnecting
to your body's cues honoring those cues
and nourishing and taking care of your
body as best as you can
no matter what weight you are at instead
of focusing on the number on the scale
or the size of your pants
pay attention to how you feel both
physically
and emotionally when your body is at its
healthiest
you'll know because you'll probably feel
more energized you might sleep better
your mood will be improved and overall
you'll just feel better
so if you want more information about
setpoint theory check out my video on
stephanie bettermore
where i dive into this in more detail
now in this video we'll be discussing
principle number nine
exercise feel the difference right away
i want to ask you a question
what does exercise mean to you what is
your attitude towards it
is it a chore is it a burden do you
genuinely enjoy it
for a lot of people exercise isn't
something that they do for fun it's
it's something that they feel that they
have to do it's been
deeply ingrained in us since we were
little kids
and all of our early experiences with
exercise have really shaped
how we feel about it today honestly when
i was in elementary school
it seemed like gym class was designed to
make some people feel superior
and others feel like the odd ones out i
was definitely the lanky
awkward not sporty kid who was always
picked last
for teams or remember having to run laps
or do suicides or push-ups
as a form of punishment do you think
that these people are
fond of running nowadays probably not i
would say also as adults
a lot of us don't enjoy movement because
we're not exercising out of love for our
body
but we're exercising out of a desire to
change it
and in a lot of cases we don't enjoy it
because we're just so motivated in the
beginning by our body goals
that we totally overdo it we go from
not working out to doing hour-long boot
camps five days a week
until we injure ourselves or become so
miserable that we throw in the towel
and if we don't see any change in our
body we may get discouraged
and just stop the thing is when most
people start a weight loss driven
exercise regime
they also start a diet at the same time
the problem with that is that the
combination of
high exercise output and low caloric
intake
tends to leave your fuel tank pretty low
the result
you're more susceptible to injuries and
so fatigued there's no
chance that you're going to enjoy it i
hate to break it to you but
just like dieting exercise does not
result in weight loss for the majority
of people
for one a 2014 review of the literature
found that most exercise programs
lead to only modest weight loss of about
2 kilograms or 4.4 pounds
which isn't a drastic amount what's more
many people ended up regaining a lot of
that weight back
just like we see with dieting by
restricting food intake
the review found that while you may see
a little modest weight loss in the short
term from exercise
this is about three times greater than
in the long term
in fact the amount of exercise energy
expenditure
had no correlation with weight loss in
the long term
this may be because our body has a lot
of compensatory
mechanisms in place to prevent you from
losing weight
excessively exercising can cause your
body to shift towards a state of
survival
and fight to reduce weight loss by
increasing your hunger
and making you feel more tired therefore
you may just end up
eating more food and moving less for
example you might not take the stairs as
often
maybe you don't do your daily chores etc
another thing to consider is that every
person has a different body
and each person responds to exercise
differently we all have different
metabolisms that are influenced by our
age
sex fat mass aerobic capacity insulin
sensitivity
and fat oxidation during exercise what's
more these variables
also influence how our body responds to
weight loss and the mechanisms it puts
in place to prevent it
such as an increased hedonistic value of
high calorie foods
finally up to 50 of people who join
fitness or exercise programs
drop out in the first six months to a
year therefore it puts into question how
sustainable
relying on exercise for long-term weight
loss really
is now just to show you that you don't
have to have exercise
every single day to reap the health
benefits outside of weight
there was a study that looked at
frequency of exercise
and its effect on weight and heart
health in the study participants were
put into two
groups high frequency activity and low
frequency activity
for the high frequency activity group
they were instructed to exercise for
about 50 minutes
per day six times a week for the low
frequency
activity group they are instructed to
exercise for a hundred minutes per day
three times a week so after 24 weeks
both groups found a decrease in
anthropometric measurements
and significant improvements in heart
health obviously this is still
a lot of exercise for both groups and i
get that this may not be sustainable for
most people
at all but the point i'm trying to make
is that it doesn't exactly
necessarily have to be extreme and
little acts of activity like walking to
work or taking the stairs can actually
add
up another crucial point is that most
research studies have participants doing
extreme amounts of exercise like
60 minutes plus of exercise per day in
fact
the american college of sports medicine
and american diabetes association
have said recommended levels of physical
activity
may help reduce weight loss however up
to 60 minutes a day
may be required when relying on exercise
alone
for weight loss since the majority of
people fail to meet the 150 minutes of
exercise per week recommendation
it's very unlikely that most people can
sustainably add
this much exercise to their daily life
i'm just saying that relying on it for
weight loss
is maybe even more dismal than relying
on diet for weight loss
for most people it doesn't work in the
long term
now while exercise may not actually be a
really great weight loss tool
it is truly so good for our health
so what are the legitimate benefits of
exercise
number one increased physical strength
one
obvious benefit is improved physical
strength and muscle building
but it's not all for aesthetics having
strength
is important for performing daily tasks
and it sure feels
awesome when you can say no i got it
when somebody needs help
what's more lean muscle mass has been
shown to improve
insulin signaling which may help reduce
the risk of metabolic disease
number two increased bone strength a lot
of people focus on muscle building when
it comes to weight-bearing exercise
but it also plays a really key role in
bone health as well
under resistance training or
weight-bearing exercise
the bones get stressed which allows
bones to break down
and rebuild bones stronger this process
is called
osteogenesis to start osteogenesis
some type of mechanical load is required
which is usually
weights or something heavy ideally with
the movement repeated at a steady rate
over time now you may be wondering if
it's really
that important at a young age since
you're probably not going to be getting
osteoporosis anytime
soon but weight-bearing exercise is
important at
any age when we're young it's about
prevention
and bone banking and lifting weights
is a great way to keep your bones strong
to prevent osteoporosis down the road
when we're older research has still
shown that lifting weights
can reduce your risk of osteoporosis so
pick up something heavy
and put it back down now number three is
improved
heart health exercise is known for its
effects on lowering blood pressure
and strengthening the heart muscle
furthermore
it's also been shown to improve levels
of hdl or
our healthy cholesterol this is
ultimately really important for keeping
our heart healthy
and decreasing the amount of stress that
you put on it number four is improved
lung health so
our heart and lungs go hand in hand the
less stress that we put on our heart
equals
less stress on our lungs and vice versa
as well
regular exercise can really improve our
aerobic performance you'll notice that
as you exercise more regularly you
aren't out of breath
quite as quickly now number five is
lowering the risk of chronic disease
so exercise has been shown to
significantly lower our risk of diseases
like heart disease diabetes high blood
pressure
osteoporosis certain types of cancer etc
number six is improved satiety cues and
appetite regulation
research has actually shown that
exercise can play a role
in regulating appetite through changes
in our hunger hormones
that is pretty cool number seven better
cognitive function
so exercise has been widely shown to
have benefits for our brain health
in fact it's been shown to increase gray
matter in the brain
improve neuroplasticity which is our
brain's ability to learn and adapt
through life
as well as to lower the risk of
neurological disorders like alzheimer's
and dementia number eight is better
sleep
you all know i need this but research
suggests that engaging in regular
movement
may help promote better sleep just keep
in mind that exercising
too close to bed may actually keep you
up so
try to exercise at least two hours
before bed or
earlier number nine is mental health
this is
last but definitely not least because
exercise can have a profound
effect on our mental health and i'd say
this is one of the main reasons that
i really encourage people to get moving
first exercise helps to lower cortisol
levels in the body that are caused
by chronic stress if we have too high
cortisol in the body
this can ultimately lead to insulin
resistance inflammation
and potentially lead to the development
of other chronic diseases
second exercise allows for the release
of feel good hormones
like norepinephrine dopamine and
serotonin which
can ultimately help improve our mood in
fact research has shown that exercise
may be a really effective treatment in
lowering depression
especially when combined with other
treatments like therapy
medications etc finally exercise is an
opportunity to get your mind
off life's problems it's not meant as an
escape
but a short respite from the stresses of
our daily life now despite all of its
benefits
i do fully appreciate that getting into
an exercise regime
is not as simple as motivation or
willpower like
you'll hear some fitness influencers say
in some cases
it takes a long time to undo the damage
that
punishing exercise has done to us it may
take us a while to build up confidence
and convince ourselves
that we are worthy and capable of it but
it's important to maybe navigate some of
the barriers that may be holding you
back
and to reestablish your relationship
with moving your body
here are some key things that you can do
to help number one
focus on how it feels it may sound
strange but
exercise is actually supposed to feel
good yes
exercise is supposed to be fun and
exciting
not pure torture so first it's really
important that you find movement
that is actually enjoyable to you some
people love to run miles
others want to lift weights and others
still prefer more low
impact activities like yoga or pilates
when you find something that you love
doing exercise becomes enjoyable
and something that you actually look
forward to next it's time to shift your
focus from calorie burning
to how exercise makes you feel both
mentally
and physically i know it's tempting to
look at the treadmill or your fitness
tracker to see how many calories you
burned or
how many steps you've taken but it does
tend to take away from the enjoyment of
exercise
and starts becoming a competition again
also these calorie trackers do not take
into consideration your personal biology
so
they are not even accurate to begin with
i did a whole video on why i broke up
with my fitbit if you want to watch it
right here but instead i want you to
focus on the following factors
both before and after you start
exercising again
number one is stress how are your stress
levels
are you able to handle stressful
situations better
are you less edgy sleep how are you
sleeping
exercise and sleep go hand in hand i
mean you'll likely notice that you're
sleeping better
as a result of moving more a sense of
well-being
what is your outlook on life like are
you more positive
energy levels do you feel more energized
and alert
on days that you exercise do you feel
like you can be more focused and ready
to take on the day
sense of empowerment do you feel more
confidence in yourself and your
abilities to perform tasks
now if you decide to take a break for
exercise i want you to first
ask yourself some of these questions
it's okay if you're feeling stressed or
you aren't sleeping well that's
that's totally normal and will actually
help you see the difference
exercise might be able to make when you
introduce exercise again
i want you to continue asking yourself
these questions
changes may not happen overnight but
you'll probably notice a gradual
increase in energy
and your confidence lower stress and
better sleep
and with those positive changes you may
actually become more motivated to
continue
exercising regularly because of how good
it makes you feel
now i also want you to separate exercise
from weight loss
as i mentioned earlier people commonly
start exercising
to lose weight and change their body but
like i said
exercise is not even a great contributor
to weight loss
and if your only goal is to lose weight
you're probably
going to lose motivation to exercise
pretty quickly when the number on the
scale
doesn't budge especially because if and
when
exercise does change your body it may be
in the form of building
muscle which can negate any weight loss
on the scale
as well i don't like linking exercise
and weight loss together because
it really diminishes the important
benefits of exercise that have
absolutely nothing to do with weight or
the size of your body
by shifting your focus to promoting your
health and quality of life
exercise gains a whole new meaning
it's really time to focus on taking care
of yourself both physically
and mentally now if you have a history
of diet mentality
it's likely that at some point you've
developed some do not exercise
traps that have prevented you from
enjoying exercise like it's meant to be
enjoyed so
let's talk about those the not worth it
trap
for a lot of people unless you are
completely dripping in sweat
and can barely breathe your exercise
didn't
count unless you exercise for over an
hour
you didn't do enough or you only
exercise twice a week instead of five
so why bother this type of talk has been
fed to us by the diet industry
and unfortunately a lot of online
influencers as well
let's make something very clear all
movement is good movement when we stop
focusing on the calories
the pounds minutes steps or the number
of sweat droplets pouring off of our
forehead
we become liberated to move in ways that
actually serve us
instead a quick walk during your lunch
break or
taking the stairs can be appreciated for
what it is
movement that feels good now if you
really need numbers consider this
let's say that you were to walk for 15
minutes during your lunch break three
times a week
you mowed the lawn 20 minutes and you
took the stairs twice per day
and it takes five minutes each time in
that week
that's 115 minutes of aerobic exercise
these simple tasks can really add up
over time and
walking has been linked to tremendous
health benefits too
yes it's important to get your heart
rate going but all those
other forms of movement that you get
throughout the week matter a lot
too next is the no time trap
look we're all busy in fact i think
we're too busy as a society
but since that's not changing anytime
soon it's time that we made
exercise a priority and included it into
our schedule
one of the most impactful things is to
actually stop saying
exercise and instead to say movement
when we say exercise we tend to go back
to the idea of this being
a large time-consuming task that has to
occur in a gym
instead movement is all-encompassing and
involves simply just
moving your body whether it's actually
going to a gym
going for a daily walk or just taking
standing breaks at work
you're adding healthy movement to your
life and if you still find that you're
struggling to find time for movement
it may be time to evaluate your
priorities and your schedule
you may be just taking on way more than
you can handle and trust me
as a self-employed mom with another on
the way
i can relate to feeling overwhelmed and
just lacking time
if you're sacrificing your health for
work or other things
i want you to think about if it's
actually worth it
no i'm not saying quit your job no i'm
not saying leave your house in complete
disarray
no i'm not saying you can't spend time
with your kids but perhaps a
conversation
with your boss about your workload is in
order or maybe
asking your partner to kind of step up
with the family and household
responsibilities
will actually help another helpful but
not always realistic option
is paying for a personal trainer or
signing up for a workout class
as soon as money gets involved it does
immediately become
a priority on pretty much anyone's
schedule skipping a session means wasted
money which means you're more likely to
make
that movement a priority yes i realize
that this is not an option for everyone
financially but if you're able to
i do find it can be really helpful
another more financially feasible option
is if you're struggling to find time to
get moving find
a workout buddy let's say you meet up
with your friend
once a week for coffee to catch up why
not ask your friend if they'd be
interested in getting a coffee to
go and going for a walk around the
neighborhood
again any movement is good movement next
we want to make exercise
fun exercise nowadays is positioned on
social media as
all heavy gym sessions in tight gym
clothing
but exercise can be anything that you
want it to be i mean it doesn't even
have to take place in a gym
first things first the number one way
that movement stops becoming fun
is when you get injured so be sure to be
careful when starting any exercise
regime
by speaking with your doctor first and
make sure that the activities that
you're taking part in
are not hurting you or putting your
health at risk in any way
so here are some examples of ways to
have fun
and move your body at the same time join
a rec league
so in most towns or cities your local
rec center will probably have sports
activities that you can join
often for free so soccer volleyball
tennis racquetball
basketball swimming you name it there
there really is something for
everyone and there are so many leagues
out there that are welcoming
beginners of all ages don't do the same
thing
every single day you don't have to just
go to the gym to be healthy
so maybe one day you play soccer with
your kids the next day you go for a walk
with your partner
the day after that you do some yoga at
home in the backyard
point being by adding variety to your
exercise regime
you're less likely to be bored
do some at-home workouts i don't know
why there's such a stigma against
at-home workouts i mean
they are an excellent way to stay active
without having to pay
a fortune for a gym membership or even
having to haul you
to the gym after co-fit 19 hit and being
stuck at home for so long
i grew to really love my online workouts
and thanks to youtube and instagram
there are a ton of free exercise videos
available for you to try
at any stage plus many of the videos use
just your body weight or a couple free
weights meaning you do not have to spend
a fortune
to be active another idea is to listen
to podcasts
i absolutely love podcasts and
fortunately
many of them are around 30 to 60 minutes
in length so
save up some podcasts that you've been
wanting to listen to and go for a walk
next we want to make exercise easier so
if you're finding it hard to find time
to work out
a really useful tip is to prepare ahead
of time
schedule time out of your day for
movement and treat it as if
it was an appointment with somebody else
even if you're all by yourself
have your gym clothes out and ready to
go the night before
put your gym shoes into a work bag for
exercise after work
find ways to make exercise less of a
hassle
and more convenient in your life next
be comfortable look i am all for a cute
pair of yoga pants
but not necessarily at the expense of a
hard workout
i feel like gym culture has created this
expectation that gym attire involves a
full
face of makeup and tight pants and a
sports bra and if that's you
great that is totally fine you do you
but if that makes you uncomfortable
don't feel like you need to conform to
society's expectations
your clothes do not determine your
workout and you don't need to take a
workout selfie in the gym year either i
mean
i definitely do not do that having said
that be
sure that you have proper shoes which
can help prevent injury and ensure that
you're putting less strain on your
joints
and fine clothing that fits well makes
you feel comfortable
and is made with a breathable material
working out is not fun when your
underwear is like glued into your crotch
with sweat so yeah make comfort a
priority
next we want to make sure to stretch
many people get injured because they
don't warm up properly i mean
for the first five minutes of any
workout it is important to do some
light movement and dynamic stretching to
warm your muscles
up again there are a ton of awesome
youtube videos out there
that can really help you out stretching
is also important for keeping your
tendons
flexible which is especially important
as we age
if your tendons get tight you're
definitely more likely to get injured
it also may be worth your while to add
some yoga into your routine once or
twice a week
which can keep your muscles and tendons
flexible
increased strength and lower stress next
remember to go beyond physical fitness
and aesthetics
i want you to focus on how movement
makes you feel
enjoy immediate benefits like improved
mood increased heart rate
and a sense of accomplishment and also
enjoy the fact that you're exercising
for your health
and well-being if exercise is consuming
your life
i want you to remember that more is not
always better
our body actually needs time to heal so
here are some red flags of exercise
abuse
an unwillingness to stop even if you're
sick or injured
feeling guilty if you miss a workout you
may have trouble sleeping this is
often a sign that you're over training
you're using exercise to compensate for
overeating so
for example running on the treadmill for
an hour to burn off that cupcake that
you ate you're feeling afraid that
you'll gain weight if you miss
one workout one week of working out etc
if any of these red flags sound like you
in your life
you may want to get a little bit of
support to improve your relationship
with exercise
next you want to schedule in rest days
so rest is arguably
more important than the exercise itself
if you're overworking your body
you're not going to give it time to
refuel and to heal
remember that you're breaking down your
muscles and your bones when you exercise
so you actually need a lot of time to
allow for your muscles and bones to
rebuild
and get stronger if not you're just
constantly breaking them down which
does way more harm than actual good and
if you miss a workout
it's no big deal just like one workout
won't transform your health or your body
missing a workout will not ruin it
either
if you ever struggle with this i want
you to tell yourself
i can always exercise tomorrow this
takes away the all or nothing mentality
that i think a lot of people have
when it comes to exercise and also with
food so if you take
anything away from this video i want you
to remember that
sometimes taking care of yourself means
not exercising
if you're exhausted and your body is
telling you it's tired
that is a sign to listen to it and to
take the day off
once you've rested you can resume
exercise with more energy
and greater enjoyment so for your
homework this week
i want you to write down three different
things that you enjoy about exercise
that have nothing to do with weight loss
by continuously reminding yourself of
all the benefits of movement
you can start to shift the narrative of
exercise towards overall health
and happiness rather than a negative
punishing experience
i want you to work on these steps
throughout your intuitive eating journey
and stay tuned for our next video on
principle number 10
honor your health with gentle nutrition
of course if you like this video don't
forget to give it
the thumbs up leave me a comment below
about
any questions that you might have about
intuitive eating so i can answer them
in an upcoming video don't forget to
subscribe to this video
and ring that little bell so that you
don't miss a single video and i will see
you next time on abby's kitchen
[Music]
bye
[Music]
you